hello everyone this is around 7 of the
1994 super tournament in Linares and
well even though both Karpov and Kramnik
are positional players
it seems car puffs positional supremacy
is too much for the 19 year old a future
world champion so let's see this game
Karpov has the white pieces and he plays
d4 we have d5 and C for the Queens
gambit c6 we have Knight to f3 Knight to
f6 Knight to c3 and East 6 the semi Slav
defense III by Karpov Knight B to d7 and
the chronic is waiting for Karpov to
develop his light-square bishop and only
after a Karpov develops the light-square
bishop will he capture d captures on c4
and not to lose any tempos so Karpov
does he plays Bishop on d3 now kramnik
captures the pawn d captures on c4
Bishop captures on c4 and b5 at the
Marin variation Fischer back to d3 and
a6 we have E 4 C 5 by chronic and the
carpel goes for d5 we have C for
attacking carp of the bishop on b3 and
Karpov plays D captures on e6 a
threatening the night on d7 and maybe
even f7 but not likely and the chronic
in this position plays F captures on e6
he could he could have captured the
bishop on d3 for example C capture son
d3 and after he captures n b7 would
check Queen captors and e7
it's not that easy for white to grab
this d3 pawn for example Knight to e5
attacking both the Queen and the d3 pawn
and now Queen to e7
well this Knight can't really move
because black will grab this
efore pawn and well if carpel would
capture this d3 pawn chronic has the
option of playing b4 now removing the
defender of the 4 pawn and after Knight
to e2 Queen captures on e4 and well this
this could be playable
although although white is better here
still so after this D captures an e6
cronic decided not to go for this he
played F captures
on e6 this was a more lone line Bishop
to c2 by Karpov Bishop to b7
Karpov castles and we have Queen to c7
Knight to g5 as chronic now has this
week six pawn and while carpal will
again make everything about this week
isolated pawn on e6 Knight the c5
chronic creates a beautiful outpost for
his Knight and c5 also now pressuring
the c4 pawn three times so we have e
five couple decides to get rid of this
weakness any four of his own and push a
five himself freeing this Bishop
unbeaten c2 but also sacrificing a pawn
for activity something not not often
seen in Karpis games so Kramnik decides
to capture the point we have Queen
captures on e5 and now rook to e1 it
seems that Karpov is the beginning some
sort of an attack after the Queen moves
but not really because chronic has the
option of Queen to b6 offering a trade
of Queens so we have Queen captures and
b6 Bishop captures on d6 and this was
probably probably one of Karpis great
preparations as well you can capture
this pawn here on e6 for example Knight
captures any six night captures any 6
and our rope captures any six would
check for example king 37 and the black
would be perfectly fine here and this is
what gromek was hoping for he has a both
players have the bishop pair and this
would this would be an okay game for
black probably probably an easy draw but
after Bishop to d6 Karpov had another
idea he played Bishop to e3 and this is
something well chronic didn't even
consider and he started spending a lot
of time here for example if you if
chronic decided to somehow defended this
pawn on e6 for example if he pushed he 5
this loses the game immediately for
example Bishop captures on c5 Bishop
captures and now ro captures on e5
checking the king and also attacking the
bishop on c5 and after Bishop
seven rook to e1 and it's not that easy
to defend at the bishop on e7 for
example you'd have to play Knight to the
g8 a very passive square for a night and
out Bishop captures on h7 threatening to
remove the defender of the bishop and
well Kramnik would have to give up the
exchange here which wrote captures h7
and the knife captures on h7 so after
this Bishop d3 move chronic decided to
castle and we have rook to d1 rook 831
now we're going to attack on this Bishop
Bishop to e7 and the Nano Bishop
captures on c5 Bishop captures on c5 and
Knight captures on e6 and this position
is much better for Karpov than capturing
the e6 point immediately in that
position so we have rook F to c8
defending the Bishop on c5 and well
Karpov doesn't capture the bishop he
doesn't consider it's that important to
remove chronics Bishop Paris he does
have a beautiful night on e6 so instead
he plays h3 now restricting this night
as the knight can't really go and go to
defy v4 g4 or he can go to h5 but this
will soon be fixed by Karpov Bishop to
f8 and we have g4 now expanding on the
King side h6 we have f4 Bishop to f3
with an attack on the rook rook to d2
Bishop back to c6 cannot remove the
coordination from from carpools rooks
but Karpov pushes g5 we have H captors
and g5 f characters and g5 now
dislodging that night from f6 we have
Knight to d7 and Karpov plays Knight
captures on f8 we have Knight captures
and I faked capturing the night with the
king would would be a blunder for
example King captures night on f8 b h7
check not allowing looking to go back at
the g8 and the threat is rook to f2 so
black would have a terrible game here so
after night to f8 he played Knight
captures on f8 and we have worked the d6
again Karpov goes for the restricting of
onyx pieces now this rook cannot move
because the bishop is attacked also the
knight can't go to g6 if the night goes
to for example h7 age 4 and again the
knight is pretty much trapped
so after this rook to d6 move Kramnik
goes for B for attacking the knight
within Knight to e4 bishop goes to e8
and now Knight to g3
we have worked to the 8th offering an
exchange of rooks Knight to f5 rook
after 76 knife captures and e6 and now
well now chronic is losing a pawn here
because his Bishop on e8 is attacked
twice and also this opponent c4 is
attacked and you can't really defend it
if you play something like Bishop to b5
you get you got rook to e4 and well you
can't really defend it the c8 square is
covered by the night and well after
Knight to d6 you could defend it maybe
we would Bishop to f7 but you get a nice
captures and I have 17 captures and then
rook to e4 and well if you try to defend
it with rooks rough to c8 you get B 3
for example B C capture some b3 and now
Bishop captures some b3 with Czech
attacking the b4 born at the King you
have to go to g6 and after age 4 and a 5
again a better position for white as
this Knight can't really can't really
come into the game and the wall with a
game being played on both sides of the
board a bishop is always much better
than a knight so after Knight to d6
chronic decided to go for a bishop to g6
trying to exchange a carp of strong
bishop and go into the game and game
being up on down we have Bishop captures
on g6 and Knight captures in g6 and
knife captures on c4 so Karpov winds up
on rock to d8
rook to e4 we have b38 capture some b3 a
temporary pawn sacrifice but now those
BB pawns are an easy target rock to d3
King to g2 defending the h3 pawn rook
captures some b3 we have h 4 nights to
it night
fate and in this position Karpov played
rook to e8 and well here a chronics flag
fell and he lost the game on time as
this was a Karpov just played move 40
and cronic failed to make his 40th move
to reach time control and he was the
game probably probably chronic was
calculating here King to f7 but it
wasn't that easy to calculate Knight to
d6 check the King can go to Jesus it's
because he loses the night so he would
have to go back and now he was probably
trying to calculate after a car pushes
h5 can he capture this pawn and also
defend the position because if Karpov
manages to push h6 and h7 would check
it's game over but unfortunately this
never happened after rook to e8 Cromley
closed the game and Karpov is 7 out of 7
next game he's playing alexei sheriff
and well he's off to a beautiful win in
winning RS 1994 so with with this game
I'm finishing the 1994 lea RC really
Nara series featuring Anatoly Karpov
for the next year so probably probably
choose maybe even choking his also his a
great win in Linares I believe it was
the 19th in 1992 when in linearis
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and also the Karpov series as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here I would like to thank
products occur for a contribution to my
channel thanks a lot I really
appreciated thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon